good morning believe nation today yes it
over to you Christian von Koenigsegg
well of course we want to infuse some
with with spirit and kind of make people
really look forward to go to work and
they can they feel that they can make a
difference it's basically about
empowering people solve this from the
canvassing perspective from mechanics a
super power company perspective a very
large company but still it's its people
and they're developing cars on a larger
scale so we still think we can get that
kind of family feeling going but it's
mostly important to empower people to
know they can make a difference and
really work together this is a really
important message because if you want to
do something big something important
you're going to have to build a team you
can't do everything yourself and you
can't micromanage everything right you
don't want to be that boss who is always
looking over somebody's shoulder
micromanage them so that they can
actually do their job if you want your
people to perform you got to give them
rope to explore to be flexible to try
out new ideas and that's where a lot of
the creativity is going to come to help
your business grow need to empower them
the other quick thought I have on this
is if you really want to grow you really
want to take it bigger places you have
to hire people to do projects for you
not tasks when you're hiring something
to do a task you're telling them what to
do do this do this do this do this and
then do that so that always relies on
your knowledge to dictate exactly what
to do whereas when you're hiring people
to do projects for you you say here's a
goal that I'd like to accomplish tell me
how we can get there and you rely on
their skills their expertise you're
hiring people who are better than you at
that certain skill set that you want to
bring them on for and that really makes
your projects rise up so empower your
people and higher for projects and not
so my question the day for you today is
how do you empower your people I love to
hear from you leave it in the comments
below thank you so much for watching
have an amazing day and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events press oh I hate it when we're
trying to record videos and the next
door neighbor's gardener comes outside
to mow the lawn